Можна бути впевненими в майбутньому, не надто оптимістичними, але впевненими.
Це одна з найважчих криз у світовій історії, яку ми коли-небудь мали.
Але з іншого боку, були й позитивні речі, приміром, те, що усі ми стали людьми, які сидять в одному човні.
Ні, я не думаю, що ми навчились достатньо.
Гадаю, ми все ще спотикаємось на нашому шляху.
У нас водії-аматори за кермом світової економіки, і це головна небезпека, з якою ми стикаємось.
Пандемія посилила співпрацю в суспільстві. Було багато співпраці між країнами. Це велике джерело інновацій.
Зараз нам потрібно розробити більш надихаюче колективне бачення майбутнього - того,
як мала б виглядати наша економіка. І зараз саме той момент для цього.
Квітень минулого року був похмурим.
Де всі?
Нині є світло у кінці тунелю. Є вакцина.
У нас є потужний інструмент для боротьби з цією пандемією. Рік тому було незрозуміло, чи буде в нас це.
Рік тому економісти намагалися передбачити, з якою рецесією ми б зіткнулися…
Рецесія у формі літери V означає різке короткочасне зниження з наступним відскоком.
W - це подвійний спад.
L - це занурення і тривалий час на дні.
На щастя це не була L-подібна рецесія.
Нам було б значно гірше без такого рівня державної підтримки.
Це було щось між V-  і W-подібною рецесією.
Це було ніби на американських гірках - вгору-вниз. Але зрештою я цілком впевнений, що зараз ми маємо тенденцію до зростання.
Щоправда, залежно від того, кого мати на увазі під "ми".
Цілком очевидно, що ми маємо справу з К-подібним відновленням.
Продовження станового розшарування суспільства, зменшення середнього класу,
концентрація робітників на низькокваліфікованих, низькооплачуваних роботах,
а окремо концентрація робітників на висококваліфікованих, високооплачуваних роботах.
Пандемія посилила нерівність.
Я думаю, що головною темою після кризи стане поглиблення прірви між багатими та бідними.
А як же рекордні суми грошей, які уряди витрачають на відбудову економіки?
Це буде лише підтримувати статус-кво, який вже й так не функціонував.
Ми більше працюватимемо з дому, а це означає більше можливостей для висококваліфікованих та високоосвічених працівників.
Ми також спостерігали стимулювання цифровізації та прискорення робочих процесів.
Знову ж таки, це на руку високоосвіченим людям і всім, хто здатний працювати в цьому цифровому світі.
Після завершення заходів підтримки можна очікувати, що в тих, кому вже було важко, справи погіршаться.
Відбувся трансфер статків на користь знову-таки багатих. І як завжди у західній економіці,
що б не робилося, вирішення проблеми робить багатих багатшими.
Колись має настати день розплати за це. Я сподіваюсь.
Рік тому економіст Даніель Штельтер сказав мені, що вирішити проблему лише грішми не вийде.
Наша стратегія останніх 30 років вирішувати всі проблеми дешевими грішми й кредитами більше не працює.
Насправді уряди ще ніколи не витрачали стільки. Але Даніель Штельтер все ще проти.
Що стало головною причиною нерівності в останні 40 років?
Легко отримувані кредити.
Було створено більше грошей, низьких процентних ставок, і щоразу, коли була криза, замість того,
щоб багаті втрачали гроші, втручався центральний банк.
Їм слід належно робити свою роботу і повертати фінансову систему до початкової ролі фінансування виробничих інвестицій, а не спекуляцій.
Якщо ви спекулюєте і помиляєтесь, ви маєте втратити гроші і не бути врятованим.
Чи є щось позитивне в усьому цьому?
Де ви бачите ОК, світ нарешті прокинувся або політики нарешті зрозуміли економіку?
Ну, жоден політик не розуміється на економіці. Я сумніваюся, чесно кажучи.
Я бачу великий ризик того, що тепер політики переконані, що саме вони керують світом.
І я думаю, що вони не зробили свою роботу в умовах кризи добре.
Я боюся, що це призведе до менш ефективних та дієвих рішень,
і тому я б сказав, що це привід для політиків отримати більше влади.
Сміливість окупиться у довгостроковій перспективі.
На часі створювати економіку спільної участі, щоб модернізувати наші освітні системи,
запровадити системи навчання протягом усього життя, створити самоокупні мережі кращого соціального захисту на майбутнє.
Все це відбувається вже зараз.
А як щодо глобалізації? Пандемія паралізувала міжнародну торгівлю.
Основною зміною з часом, я сподіваюся, буде більша локалізація виробництва.
Я думаю, що у нас занадто довгі ланцюжки поставок, які базуються на використанні дешевої робочої сили
та решти світу, а не на розвитку внутрішньої економіки, де насправді і відбувається споживання.
Я не думаю, що глобалізація буде замінена регіоналізацією або локалізацією.
Ми не повинні забувати, що локально сконцентроване виробництво також має певні ризики.
Чого варто прагнути, я вважаю, так це менше орієнтуватися, скажімо так, на найдешевшого постачальника.
Натомість більше диверсифікувати, щоб бути більш стійким у майбутніх кризах.
Але це може призвести навіть до більшої, а не меншої глобалізації.
Я дуже скептично ставлюся до законів про ланцюги поставок,
оскільки вони розділяють ринки праці в бідних країнах, залежних від сировинних товарів.
І це не той спосіб, який дозволив би біднішим країн технологічно наздогнати розвинуті.
Погано, що країни, які розвиваються, завжди лишаються експортерами сировини.
Це не шлях до розвитку та процвітання.
Криза дала усім нам час поміркувати. Довкілля тим часом змогло передихнути. Але ненадовго.
Звідки б не походив цей вірус, навіть якщо він походив з лабораторії Уханя,
кінцевою причиною цієї кризи був надмірний тиск людини на біосферу. І траплятиметься знову і знову.
Світло в кінці тунелю - можливо, лісова пожежа, яка спалить усі наші фабрики.
Всі ми бачили одне страшне попередження за іншим про те, що ми довели планету до межі,
а наші нинішні економічні системи несумісні зі сталою й дружньою до довкілля економікою.
Ми маємо змінити наші споживацькі звички.
Якщо ми це зробимо, то, можливо, матимемо й більше соціальних взаємозв’язків і згуртованості, ніж раніше.
Це також показало нам, що, можливо, ми можемо подорожувати трохи менше, робити більше з дому.
Це вже було б більш екологічно. Тож, гадаю, є і кілька позитивних моментів.
Але, звісно, краще нехай наступна пандемія не настане раніше, ніж через 100 років.
Ну, ще ця не закінчилася. Але будемо сподіватися, що ми краще підготуємось до наступної. У нас вже достатньо досвіду!
І більше ніж достатньо локдаунів і часу проведеного в ізоляції.